(audience cheering)
- Thank you!
Oh my goodness.
- I know!
(audience cheering)
- You guys.
- You guys know how to
make a lady feel welcome.
- Okay.
- Where do we begin?
Oh, which is like the book.
- So this is my copy.
- Uh-huh.
- And, as you know, on this show,
we've tried to build something
that is whiplash comedy
at one moment, because
we all need to laugh,
and it's my survival
and coping mechanism.
- Me too.
- But we also wanna figure
out how to live a life here.
- Mhmm, yeah.
- And I can't think of anyone
who I'd wanna hold a conversation
about how to do such
a thing than with you.
(audience cheering)
Lately, I've been working
out a lot of stuff
with my own life,
and I appreciate my own
family and my mom so much.
But when I was reading this book at night
and coming home from work,
which we take with us,
so anyone who compartmentalizes,
you know, personal and
professional, my hat's off to you,
because usually it bleeds
all together for me.
And I would hold your
book to my chest at night
and I would wish that
I was in your family,
that you were my mom or my sister,
and I feel like everybody feels like that.
My friend, who do you see
yourself as to everybody?
- You know, I have never
thought about that in that way.
I mean, I wanna be a support to people
to the extent that I can.
That's one of the reasons why
I wrote "The Light We Carry."
Because I was, you know,
in a time of uncertainty
when I wrote this book,
in the middle of the quarantine,
tucked away with my family.
My girls had come home from college.
They were afraid, like everybody else.
And I had to think about what tools
I had to lean on to get through.
Because one of the
reasons why I'm so candid
is that people think
that folks in high places
have all the answers.
We do not, we have a
lot of the same fears.
All we have are the tools that we develop
over the course of a lifetime.
So I thought, "Well, let
me put this in a book."
So I did my best to put
as much of the wisdom
that I've accumulated
over this almost 60 years.
Yes, January, 60.
(audience clapping)
And to share some of those
insights with my friends,
my sisters, the people who look up to me,
the people who are asking those questions.
So I don't think it's one thing,
it's kinda like whatever somebody needs
to be able to hear something
that can help them.
- Well, speaking of tools,
I would like to ask you one for myself.
- Yes.
- Funny story, I was with...
- Michelle.
- Okay, thank you.
I was with Michelle one morning.
I was lucky enough to moderate
a beautiful discussion
with children about something
me and my family love,
"Waffle + Mochi."
- [Michelle] The Netflix
special about food.
It's a food adventure.
- We connected, it was everything.
I leave, I go about my day.
And that evening I'm
at the George Clooney,
George and Amal Clooney
Foundation Gala Awards.
- Yeah.
- And I see you across the room.
You are with Meryl Streep,
John Oliver, George Clooney,
and I think like a few other
of the top functioning
people in the planet.
(Michelle and Audience laughing)
And I sat there and I didn't
know how to walk up to you.
- Aw.
- I was like,
"I think that's just too intimidating
of a circle."
- Well, you probably would've been blocked
by an agent or something too.
So I'm glad you didn't try
and feel the hand of an agent.
But you could've, you
know, and you should've.
- Well, I'm single for seven years,
so maybe it wouldn't have
been a bad thing, but.
(Audience and Michelle laughing)
(audience clapping)
- [Michelle] And a lot of 'em are cute.
(upbeat music)